Fortnite is a fun, new survival game from Epic Games that offers players a unique experience.
Instead of simply building a base, you'll need to scavenge for supplies and complete different missions...
...all while holding off the endless hordes of husks that seem to fall from the sky...
...whenever something bad happens.
In this video, we will address the game's basic systems and help you get the hang of everything...
...as you dive into Fortnite to get started for the first time.
Scavenging is one of your primary goals in Fortnite,...
...and if you want to make it anywhere in the game,...
...you're going to need to get used to keeping your supplies backpack...
...filled with items like stone, metal and wood.
These are the basic building blocks you'll use to build up structures like walls and floors,...
...and you'll need to have plenty of them on you at all times.
Trust us, you can easily scavenge wood from trees and other wooden things...
...like logs and even some wooden structures.
If you want metal, we suggest hitting up pipes or even cars.
You can also find stashes of metal ore in caves on more forest space missions.
So, be sure to look around for ways to go deeper in the map.
You'll find more metal in city-based missions...
...where you can find cars and even metal poles to break down.
The best way to get stone is to look around for large rocks...
...that you can hit with your pickaxe.
These are often found in every map,...
...but they are most abundant in maps that take place in forests or on the outskirts of the city.
Schematics are your main way of getting new weapons,...
...and these items can be attained by finding chests during missions...
...or by bursting open llamas in the loot tab on the main menu.